welcome to another famous Friday I
believe that whatever goal you have
whatever mission you're on whatever
challenges you're coming up against
somebody has already solved it and
instead of you trying to reinvent the
wheel come up with every new idea
yourself model success find someone
who's already accomplished what you want
to accomplish see what worked for them
and apply it to your business so today I
want to look at the success behind Ray
Kroc who's the man who built up
McDonald's and his lesson is it's never
too late to start
so Ray Kroc was 50 years old he was
selling milkshake makers okay he was
representing the company's going out and
selling the machines to help you create
milkshakes and he basically was
traveling across the United States to
all these different restaurants into all
these different soda shop fountains
selling his milkshake maker there was a
problem though he was having some
initial early success but then he
started losing customers because in the
50s people were leaving cities and
moving to the suburbs and as a result
all of the restaurants and soda shop
fountains in the city we're having a
hard time staying afloat a lot of them
are going out of business and so they
weren't ordering new equipment and Kroc
was now suffering and think about it
this is a really important part in
somebody's life right when your business
isn't working and when you're 50 years
old a lot of people at that point would
say I should go back and get a job I
don't know I gotta find something to do
I'm worried about my retirement what am
I gonna do I'm too I'm too old to start
a new business I can't start this all
over again I need some some security but
not Ray Kroc that was in the story he
told himself instead he said you know
what I'm going to make my own destiny
I'm gonna go find a new opportunity that
I can hang my hat on and be proud that I
built and so he found that through one
of his customers and there was this one
store in California that bought eight
new milkshake mixers from him and this
is a time one you know most companies
are buying one or two milkshake mixers
and at this point most people weren't
buying anything from you anymore they
were going out of business and here's a
company in California they wanted to buy
eight that means it can make 40 mmm
shakez at a time he had to go see the
company figure what was going on why
they were so successful he visited them
it was run by dick and Mac McDonald and
the company was called McDonald's it was
a very simple store they had no indoor
seating they had a very limited menu of
just cheeseburgers hamburgers french
fries soft drinks and milkshakes that's
it that's all you could buy there he saw
the success they were having and said
you guys could go international you guys
could have thousands of locations around
the world you guys could make a ton of
money beyond just having this one
location and they didn't want to do that
they wanted to just run their location
and so they agreed to give Kroc the
marketing rights to go and promote
McDonald's across the country and later
around the world
and here's Ray Kroc right 50 years old
not having a stable source of income
where most people are worried about
retirement where most people are
thinking they're too old to start
something new and and go travel across
the country pulling a brand new business
and put it all on the line too trusting
yourself you can make something new
happen when your last business started
failing that's where most people are in
Kroc said no I'm going to make my dream
happen and he bet on himself and he
started growing locations across the
country and he eventually bought out the
brothers for 2.7 million dollars and
became the only owner of McDonald's and
grew it to I don't know how big
McDonald's is now Multi multi
multi-billion dollar company and he had
massive success and he started it when
he was 50 years old this is an important
lesson guys because if you're at that
point where you're not happy with your
life where you're in your 50s or
approaching and you're you know you
don't know what to do you don't like
your job or your business isn't doing
well and you may not have the courage to
start up and do something on your own
and you tell yourself I'm too old to
start you got to understand that that is
just a story you're telling yourself and
as long as you believe that story then
it's going to become your reality
be like Ray Kroc and bet on yourself I
know that you're never too old to start
believe for those you're watching like
the video you can subscribe to the
channel to see more just like it
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon every week I share my best
information to help you fuel your
business forward in my newsletter check
it out below
hi I'm Jason Grif on sigur rós
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's deep only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period